so you're exxon mobil in the 90s
you're one of the biggest oil companies
in the world and because of that you
have a lot of global influence
the only problem is you're an american
company and as a multinational
corporation your business practices
don't always align with the us's foreign
policy
sometimes america's dictator of the
month happens to be someone you're doing
business with or the world family who
just signed their country's oil away
turns out to be america's next target to
liberate that kind of thing having us
politics interfere with your business
model is a pesky inconvenience your
solution to become one of the most
powerful organizations on earth
comparable to an actual government or
sovereign nation we'll increase our
ability to participate in more of the
new opportunities
in the global oil and chemical business
by doing that you have your own foreign
policy your own climate policy and even
a pseudo embassy where world leaders can
meet to help you take over the global
oil supply it's gone so far that exxon
mobil is one of the most important
geopolitical influences in the world
quote able to determine american foreign
policy and the fate of entire nations
end quote
exxon mobil is what we call a private
empire it's a story of how a single
company can rise up to challenge entire
nation states and this private empire
all started with one of history's
greatest businessmen
john d rockefeller
[Music]
i'm worried about future oil supplies
what's exxon doing to help
we've already invested three billion
dollars in alaska and in the years ahead
we'll invest billions more up here to
supply the rest of the us with oil and
gas and we're exploring north of alaska
in the arctic ocean where we will need
to build man-made islands to hold our
drilling rigs it will clearly take more
than one company's efforts to solve our
energy problems but exxon is helping to
solve some of them because energy is our
business
oh
sorry
you look under the hood i'll take care
of this
most service stations are just service
stations but a standard oil station is
something else
[Music]
john d rockefeller created the standard
oil company in 1870
it was the start of america's oil rush
and rockefeller wanted as much control
of the market as possible
unfortunately the government deemed
there is such a thing as too much
control and 40 years later standard oil
is declared a monopoly and is split into
34 smaller companies
luckily for rockefeller he has shares in
almost every single one of those 34
businesses so he eventually made even
more money than he would have if
standard oil survived
two descendants of standard oil were
exxon and mobile
exxon was the most direct descendant of
standard oil and mobile was exxon's
biggest competitor they had a fierce
competition going for decades until in
1998 the two companies decided to merge
these synergy benefits come as a result
of the merger the idea was to recreate
their glory days as an almost monopoly
on us oil by reuniting the two biggest
companies stemming from standard oil
exxonmobil became one of the biggest
corporations in the world by both
revenue and market cap
there was nowhere to go but up
except for one small detail
oil supply
for years only the elite like exxon have
been able to invest in the best asset
classes while us smaller investors have
been left in the dust and one of those
exclusive asset classes is fine arts
while according to our price blue chip
our prices have outpaced the s p 500 by
168 from 1995 to 2021. the problem is
this asset class has been traditionally
controlled by the rich for the rich by
the mere fact that they're the only ones
who have a few million dollars to drop
on a single piece of arts but not
anymore because that's where masterworks
comes in with masterworks average
everyday people like you can finally tap
into this lucrative art market by owning
a fraction of a great piece of arts
here's how it works their research team
selects the artists that have the most
momentum using their proprietary data
they then purchase a great piece of art
at a fair price they securitize the
artwork through the sec so that anyone
can invest in it and that's where you
come in you can invest in a fraction of
that artwork so you have fractional
ownership in it masterworks then holds
it for three to ten years before selling
the painting and boom you receive your
cut of the sale after their fees or you
can even sell your shares of the artwork
on what's called the secondary market if
you don't want to wait that long what's
great is that masterworks has a great
track record with historical performance
of 15 net of fee since their inception
so what are you waiting for get in on
this exclusive asset class by going to
masterworks.rtran right now the link is
on the screen and in the video
description below it's free to get
started and unlike actual art galleries
it's free to look again that's
masterworks.art slash j trim with the
link below thanks to masterworks for
sponsoring this video
but for america they are more ominous
they tell the arabs that their oil
weapon is wounding america the country
that supports and supplies their enemy
israel they tell the government that
america is vulnerable and that her
supplies of energy are not inexhaustible
after the 1973 oil crisis there was a
massive oil shortage in the us
for years exxon had very good ties to
the middle east in 1953 you even
supplied the ruler of oman with money so
that he could raise an army that led to
a 5 year war in oman basically exxon did
what the us government usually does
funding dictators which usually led to
wars in exchange you got a massive oil
concession which shows just how
profitable doing business with dictators
can be unfortunately by the late 90s
these favors had pretty much dried up
the oil embargo had ruined relations
between u.s oil companies and the middle
east so you needed a new stable oil
supply fast
one tactic was to try to persuade oil
countries that you could deliver massive
amounts of cash in exchange to rights to
extract oil unfortunately countries like
china and russia were looking to do the
same thing except they could offer a lot
more favors in return
loans weapons sales and geopolitical
favors you just couldn't compete by the
90s you ranked 14 on the list of the
biggest oil companies right underneath
corporations like armaco and saudi
arabia and gazprom in russia exxon
merges with mobile to form exxon mobil
in 1998 and when the early 2000s came
around you were desperate to get to the
top so you made a plan you would take
advantage of the power vacuum and
instability during the iraq war by
moving your operations into iraq
together with companies like bp and the
world dutch shell exxon mobil increased
oil production facilities and finally
some more oil came flowing into the
company whether or not the iraqi people
benefited from it was irrelevant until
the power vacuum was filled and the
country was stable you would be milking
it for all it's worth
exxon mobil was finally moving up the
ladder again and what they came new
opportunities to implement your unique
foreign policy around the world
we're exxon we're bob vesper who helped
find oil 40 miles off the louisiana
coast
we're jerome degree who's producing the
oil from that find
we're tom witt who helps move the oil
ashore
we're jan warman who refines it into
gasoline
we're bob danaher who sees that the
gasoline gets to you we're more than 100
000 people working on energy we're exxon
us politics often got in the way of your
goals outside the us but what if you
could disregard them to do so you would
either have to be great at lobbying or
influencing the white house or you would
need a man on the inside over the next
20 plus years you would have both and it
started with the election of george bush
in 2001 president bush came from an oil
loving family him and dick cheney his
vice president were pretty much big
oil's dream team while he was
campaigning bush got 1.5 million dollars
in donation from the oil industry at the
same time it was the biggest ever
donation to a single candidate and when
he was inaugurated well it was time to
return the favor
exile mobile has so much influence with
the white house it was common knowledge
that quotes when the corporation's
washington representatives needed a
meeting they almost always got one end
quote
unlike other companies you chose to
avoid asking for specific favors instead
you used the white house as a source of
information
what the people on the hill didn't
realize was that the info you were
gathering would help you set up your own
little oil empire with their own foreign
policy just like any other sovereign
states
one of the first independent political
decisions exxon mobil made was going up
against hugo chavez and venezuela exxon
mobil and venezuela had a long history
but when hugo chavez became president he
suddenly wanted to nationalize oil this
meant that he wanted to take the oil
industry away from private companies
like exxon mobil and have the government
run it obviously losing your operation
to the venezuelan government was a
nightmare so instead of caving you took
it to the world bank in the end the
world bank sided with you and so did the
us you got to claim over 16 billion
dollars from venezuela over the years
even while venezuela became one of the
poorest countries in the world
even after the economic crisis started
you still gunned for more money asking
for another 1.6 billion in 2014. today
the average income in venezuela is
around 53 dollars
[Music]
in chad you took a more gentle approach
at its weakest and most vulnerable
moments you came like a knight in shiny
armor offering economic freedom and
development in exchange for oil oil
wasn't going to help the country build
its healthcare or education system they
needed money and money was something you
would happily give in exchange for their
natural resources at first it seemed
like a fair trade but exxon mobil snuck
something into the contract right
underneath their noses article 34 of the
contract states that no matter what no
matter the law or the government's
opinion no one could change the
agreement without exxon mobil's
permission not even future governments
of chad you had gotten them right where
you wanted them and until today exxon
mobil still operates in chad one of the
poorest countries in the world and all
that development and infrastructure you
promised while most people in chat still
don't have access to a steady food or
water supply and decent housing and
medicine is almost non-existent with
only one doctor per 38 000 people
just like u.s foreign policy you have
made it a habit of promising
unbelievable growth and development and
once you got what you wanted all of that
was thrown out the window
so far your deals were other countries
were borderline unethical sure you have
made some shady moves but most of it
could be excused by the cutthroat nature
of the business that was until you got
involved in the conflict in indonesia
between 1976 and 2005 a group of rebels
fought against the indonesian army to
make the province of atte independence
around the same time mobile was
operating in the arun gas fields in the
region when the conflict broke out
mobile and then exxon mobil hired
military units from the indonesian army
to keep their facilities in operation
safe yes the company mobile then exxon
mobil had its own private army you
claimed it was all in the name of
keeping your employees away from danger
but conveniently omitted the fact that
those same military units were
committing horrible human rights
violations against the local people
every violation in the book was
committed by these military units who
often use the money you paid them to get
more weapons and recruits the company's
excuse you never knew you were just
trying to keep your business going in
2001 11 villagers sued exxon mobil for
being complicit in the human rights
abuses in 2015 you sold your operations
enacted to another company and in 2017
litigation was still ongoing
[Music]
around this point in time you realize
that you needed some serious influence
in the white house to keep you out of
trouble so when donald trump became
president and chose rex tillerson as
secretary of state your luck couldn't be
better tillerson joined exxon in 1975
and stayed all the way through the
merger to become chairman and ceo of the
company in 2006. he lobbied to stop a
world that would force exxon mobil to
disclose their payments to foreign
governments and then in 2017 one hour
before being confirmed as secretary of
state that rule was completely
overturned rex tillerson was a company
man through and through and finally you
had a die-hard supporter on the inside
[Music]
equatorial guinea had a dictator as
president for 42 years while his people
suffered and more than 70 percent lived
in poverty him and his family owned
houses in malibu collected michael
jackson memorabilia and own at least six
rare supercars where does all that money
come from you of course just like the us
government if a dictator is good for
business we can turn a blind eye in
equatorial guinea the president's family
runs everything they always have and
when you're supposed to pay the country
for rights to mine the oil well that
money goes straight into the ruling
family's bank account in washington
which just goes to show that for you no
foreign policy is quite as important as
that of the united states of exxonmobil
huh seven ingredients for better gas
mileage
wonder what they are corrosion inhibitor
solvent fluid
demulsifier
[Applause]
fuel detergent number one
pure detergent number two
[Applause]
anti-adhesion compound and marker
molecules
wow
i did not know that
with seven key ingredients new synergy
gasoline is engineered to help give you
better gas mileage
[Applause]
today's exxon mobil's carefree days of
supporting wars and dictators seems to
be catching up their investment rating
has been cut to double a minus which is
not good they're being faced with
investigations from several attorney
generals and they're being accused of
misleading investors despite this exxon
mobil still seems to live by the motto
of no one likes us but we don't care
for longer documentaries just like this
one that goes over everything they'll
never teach you in business school that
are also too controversial to be ever
released to the public click that join
button below you'll get access to
private documentaries every month for
just 5 a month unlike the cost of
business school and if you join and
don't think it's worth the money you can
email me and i will personally refund
you no questions asked the next private
documentary coming out is on mk ultra
the cia's mind control program and the
one after that is probably going to be
on our friend every jepstein you can
preview the documentaries that are
already out at any time with this link
below which includes the one on monsanto
the company that owns the world's food
supply sign up right now with the join
button below or the link below if you
don't see the join button you won't
regret it
[Music]
[Music]
you